I assure you that I am the book of fate
questions are my enemies for my
questions explode answers leap up like a
frightened flock blackening the sky of
my inescapable memories not one answer
not one suffices
what prisms flash when I enter the
terrible field of my past I am a chip of
shattered Flint enclosed in a box the
Box gyrates and quakes
I am tossed about in a storm of
mysteries and when the box opens I
return to this presence like a stranger
in a primitive land slowly slowly I say
I relearn my name but that is not to
know myself this person of my name this
Leto who is the second of that calling
finds other voices in his mind other
names and other places oh I promise you
as I have been promised that I answer to
but a single name if you say Leto
I respond sufferance makes this true
sufferance and one thing more I hold the
threads all of them are mine let me but
imagine a topic say men who have died by
the sword and I have them in all their
gore every image intact every moan every
grimace joys of motherhood I think and
the birthing beds are mine cereal baby
smiles and the sweet cooing z' of new
generations the first walking's of the
toddlers and the first victories of use
brought forth for me to share
they tumble one upon another until I can
see little else but sameness and
repetition keep it all in tact
I warned myself who can deny the value
of such experiences the worth of
learning through which I view each new
instant ah but it's the past don't you
understand
it's only the past this morning I was
born in a yurt at the edge of a horse
plane in a land of a planet that no
longer exists
tomorrow I will be born somewhere else
in another place I have not yet chosen
this morning No ah this life when my
eyes had learned to focus I looked out
at sunshine on trampled grass and I saw
vigorous people going about the sweet
activities of their lives where oh where
has all of that vigour gone the God in
prayer later the second the stolen
journals but it's like a balloon the
surface of the balloon is their face
with what we do not know inside the
balloon as we blow into it is what we
have proved but as we increase what we
think we know we increase our exposure
to what we do not know this is one of
the inevitable laws of our universe
but isn't it more interesting to live in
a universe where there are unknowns to
discover new lands to explore then to
live in an absolute box where when you
find the edge no place to go from there
I like the fact that we cannot predict
everything I like the fact that we live
in a universe or anything may happen
because the alternative to me is a
constricting dead end
[Music]
God in fur of Doom is the fourth book in
Frank Herbert's dune saga the novel
takes place 3,500 years after the events
of the previous novel in the series
Children of Dune later the second of
House Atreides has ruled the Empire with
an iron fist since that time the sand
trout skin which Leto had first put on
and shulock has grown and changed him in
the early stages of Latos transformation
which is referred to in the novels as
his metamorphosis Leto was mostly human
the symbiotes skin had given him
incredibly amplified strength immunity
to conventional attacks and prevented
him from aging but later always knew
what would become of him eventually the
skin which was not his own consisted of
many interlocking tiny sand vectors Leto
knew that approximately 4,000 years
after he had put on a living suit the
completed transformation of the sand
trout into their adult warm phase would
destroy him later calls this his final
metamorphosis I often think about my
final metamorphosis that likeness of
death I know the way it must come but I
do not know the moment or the players
this is one thing I cannot know I only
know whether the Golden Path continues
or intz the Golden Path is Latos grand
plan for Humanity it is a path that his
father Paul Atreides saw but rejected in
the time that the god emperor of dune
takes place Leto and the sand trout
sylia have become one body Leto is a pre
worm seven meters long and two meters in
diameter
his body weighs approximately five
tonnes and is carried around by the
Royal cart a technology created by the
exceedance one of the fringe worlds on
the outskirts of the empire who
maintained rule over their home when
through technocracy Latos body is ribbed
down it's linked only his face remains
it is at the height it would be had he a
man's body though his arms and hands
were still functional and seemingly
human his legs had atrophied and become
useless long ago mostly Leto is in
control of the pre-warm body but there
are also reflexes beyond his control the
pre-warm body for instance would react
to protect itself if threatened the god
emperor maintained supreme control over
the universe Arrakis is now a wet planet
fully terraformed with clouds lakes and
rivers and forests the great worms of
Arrakis died out long ago and no more
spice is being produced Leto kept his
hoard of spice well hidden no one truly
knew how much he possessed the spacing
guilds dependency on spice made them
almost reliable as allies no one moved
in the universe without the permission
of the God Emperor all spice in the
universe was rationed by the god emperor
himself and he could deny rations to
those who displeased him much of the
novel god emperor of doom is told from
the perspective of later the second by
use of a Nixie and device called a
dictator Leto can cast his thoughts in a
particular mode and have the words
printed out on radula and crystal sheets
one radula in Crystal sheet is a mere
molecule in thickness Leto could then
have them copied onto less permanent
material God umber of dune opens
sometime in the distant future as the
god Emperor's journals which were
discovered long after his death are
being read and studied for historical
insight these journals are a completion
to the legendary documents known as
Leto's stolen journals which were stolen
from the Citadel on Arrakis during his
reign as god emperor
the plot begins as ciona Atreides
escapes with the stolen journals two
books printed on crystal paper see ona
is highly important to Leto the most
recent result of his breeding program
which he had snatched from the many
Jesuit sisterhood over 3,000 years ago
Acciona and her party escapes with the
God Emperor's journals Latos D wolves
are unleashed upon them they had stolen
the journals from the fortress in the
sarire see ona and her two accomplices
are pursued by the creatures through
Latos forbidden forest Hulot dies first
as one of the wolves violently rips out
his shoulder and the rest of the pack
pounces the d wolves were allowed to eat
anything they caught in the Forbidden
Forest but the D wolves did not stop to
eat
they knew that two more humans ran
through the forest the second to die was
crew tagging whose ancestor had served
that siege to war back in the days when
Arrakis was still called doom C ona had
been the fastest which is why she had
been holding the packet containing the
stolen journals they had known the risk
would be great but they knew that the
secret of where Leto hoarded his spice
would be worth it kou Tang had
sacrificed himself delaying the D wolves
to help C own escape with the journals
once ciona escapes the forests and
crosses the Idaho River the wolves do
not cross it they had been conditioned
to stop at the water to know the
boundaries of their territories zeona
had escaped with two of Latos journals
items of immeasurable value C ona knows
that the people of the Imperium have no
true lives of their own the populace
lived in neat rectangular houses wood
flat black roofs constant sameness and
this was repeated on every planet in the
worm gods Empire even planetary capitals
she said were nothing more than large
villages of the kind found everywhere in
the Empire even though even the poorest
families are well-fed their daily lives
grow more and more static with the
passage of time see ona admires the
ancient Freeman because they were truly
free and the worms Empire he went only
where the worm demanded according to the
god emperor this was for the sake of
Latos peace but see ona had spied on the
god emperor and her father man ale as a
child and what she had heard had planted
a seed of hatred for Leto in her mind he
says he denies us most crises to limit
our forming forces he said people can be
sustained by affliction but I am the
affliction now gods can become
afflictions those were his words Duncan
the worm is a sickness ciona Atreides
despises the worm God and those that she
will be his end in C ona's mind Leto has
no right to call himself God no right to
impose his tyranny upon the universe she
is certain that the information in his
journals will be enough to undo him
zeona calls the worms Empire a prison I
will destroy you Leto not we will
destroy you
that was Nazi honest way she would do it
herself she turned and strode toward the
orchards beyond the rivers mowed border
as she walked she repeated her oath
adding to it allowed the old Freeman
formula which terminated in her full
name
zeona eben fed Asifa Atreides it is who
curses you Leto you will pay in full
Leto finds ciona fascinating he had not
predicted that she would take the
journals this gave him great pleasure he
had watched her in the Forbidden Forest
by use of his devices he could have
stopped the D wolves at any time but
chose not to calling them an extension
of his purpose his purpose to be the
greatest predator that mankind has ever
known
throughout the millennia later the
second has at the Tleilaxu produced
countless duncan idaho golus Leto use
duncan idaho golas as his commander of
the Royal Guard he also used them in his
breeding program occasionally the
Duncan's always treated towards
subversion however but this was
precisely the reason that the Duncan's
were used at the start of the novel
Latos current duncan who has served him
in the past 60 years attempts to kill
him after discovering that the play
lacks who are working on his replacement
he knows that later the second has vowed
not to use his prescient power to
predict the moment of his own death and
he believes that a latest gun can kill
him the Duncan concealing the weapon
which Leto already knows about having
been informed by the guild had come to
talk to Leto about ciona and her
rebellion this bores the god Emperor he
recognizes predictable patterns in the
rebellious all rebellions are ordinary
and in ultimate boar they are copied out
of the same pattern one much like
another the driving force is adrenaline
addiction and the desire to gain
personal power all rebels are closeted
aristocrats that's why I can convert
them so easily why do the Duncan's never
really hear me when I tell them about
this the god invar insists that radicals
always see the world in binary terms
simple us versus limb or good versus
evil in addressing more complex issues
this way these radicals create a window
into chaos the god emperor states that
government is the mastery of chaos which
contrary to the belief of many has
predictable characteristics Leto says
that radicals only create new radicals
continuing the old process a radical
that saw the complexities however was in
fact no true radical but a rival for
leadership and must either be killed or
co-opted
Duncan I am all of them and I know there
has never truly been a selfless rebel
just hypocrites conscious hypocrites or
unconscious hypocrites it's all the same
lost in thought and bored of the talk of
rebels Leto does not initially noticed
the layest gone that the Duncan has
pointed directly at him you Duncan have
you betrayed me to err to brute every
fiber of Latos awareness came to full
alert he could feel his body twitching
the worm flesh had a will of its own
idaho spoke with derision
tell me Leto how many times must I pay
the debt of loyalty Leto recognized the
inner question how many of me have there
been the Duncans always wanted to know
this every Duncan asked it and no answer
satisfied they doubted in his saddest
more deep voice Leto asked do you take
no pride in my admiration Duncan haven't
you ever wondered what it is about you
that makes me desire you as my constant
companion through the centuries you know
me to be the ultimate fool dumped in the
voice of an angry mood Eve could always
be counted on to shatter idaho despite
the fact that idaho knew no mini jesuit
had ever mastered the powers of voice as
late too had mastered them it was
predictable that he would dance to this
one voice the lace gun wavered in his
hand that was enough Leto was off the
cart in a hurtling roll Idaho had never
seen him leave the cart this way had not
even suspected it could happen for Leto
there are only two requirements a real
threat which the worm body could sense
and the release of that body the rest
was automatic and the speed of it always
astonished even Leto the Lay's gun was a
major concern it could scratch him badly
but few understood the abilities of the
pre-warm body to deal with heat Leto
struck Idaho while rolling and the Lay's
gun was deflected as it was fired one of
the useless flippers which had been
Latos legs and feet sent a shocking
burst of sensations crashing
to his awareness for an instant there
was only pain but the warm body was free
to act and reflexes ignited of violent
paroxysm of flopping Leto heard bones
cracking the Leia's gun was thrown far
across the floor of the crypt by a
spasmodic jerk of idaho's hand rolling
off of idaho Leto poised himself for a
renewed attack but there was no need
the injured flipper still sent pain
signals and he sensed that the tip of
the flipper had been burned away the
sand trout skin already sealed the wound
the pain had eased to an ugly throbbing
Idaho stirred there could be little
doubt that he had been mortally injured
his chest was visibly crushed there was
obvious agony when he tried to breathe
but he opened his eyes and stared up at
Leto the persistence of these mortal
possessions later thought ciona
idaho gasped Leto saw the life leave him
then this was not the first time a
duncan had died by Latos hands in truth
only 19 Duncan's had died by natural
causes after the Duncan dies later
wonders if ciona and duncan could have
been mates but he dismisses the idea but
Leto does note however that the duncan
had been aiming for his brain his brain
was no longer a brain of human
dimensions not even associated with his
face it had spread throughout his body
this was a fact he had told only to his
journals inwardly Leto possessed a
vantage point by which to view his
ancestral memories without fear of being
overcome he could reach back and gaze
through the eyes of any person in those
memories in this way he was unlike
anyone who had ever lived before him
even his sister Janina he had mastered
his inner lives and could speak with the
voices of his ancestors though his power
is great it causes him to struggle with
unbearable boredom
having seen the near extent of all human
potential Leto said that to be thought
of as a God as he was became ultimately
boring
the stolen journals state that holy
boredom is a good and sufficient enough
reason for the invention of free will
this is key in understanding the role
that Leto intends for ciona
in his golden path Latos rule of the
universe was maintained by his fish
speaker legions the fish speakers were
led to his military force during his
reign as God umber of the Imperium
finding that the Freeman and the sardick
are were unable to suit his needs later
the second founded his all-female army
the fish speakers maintained Garrison's
on every planet throughout the Imperium
according to the god Emperor
male militaries were ultimately
predatory and would eventually turn
against the civilian population in times
of peace when there was no enemy to
fight females on the other hand would
remain calm and tamed during peacetime
fish speaker schools could be found in
the festival city on Arrakis Leto had
given them the name fish speakers
because according to his genetic memory
the first priestesses spoke to fish in
their dreams Leto said this was of great
value the fish speakers were extremely
loyal followers of the god Emperor's
religion they reacted violently to
anything and they considered to be
heresy against their one true God the
fish speakers were the enforcers of
Latos peace which was necessary for the
Golden Path in terms of longevity and
the number of planets ruled the fish
speakers can be thought of as the most
effective military force of all time men
were almost completely shut out of the
fish speaker combat forces the only role
that men served in the Lions of fish
speaker women was that of husbands fish
speakers were trained to be extremely
effective disciplined and even fanatical
soldiers Leto however rejected the idea
that fish speakers should be thought of
as a police force by my name I assure
you that it's not so police are
inevitably corrupted police always
observed that criminals prosper it takes
a pretty dull policeman to miss the fact
that the position of authority is the
most prosperous criminal position
available
the fish speakers could not be corrupted
the fish speakers were more than an army
the women also served as the god empress
governmental bureaucracy they were
activists courtiers pages teachers fish
speaker priestesses served as judge and
jury and executioner the fish speakers
also served roles as assassins and
secret agents and any other use that the
gaudy emperor saw fit a fish bigger
would fall upon her own blade without
hesitation if Leto commanded it Nayla is
the most prominent fish speaker in the
doom series Nayla was a large hulking
figure her strength was legendary the
god invar himself had once seen her lift
a hundred kilo man with one hand she has
been commanded to obey see own Atreides
in all things by late of the second even
though Siana plots to destroy the god
emperor this is a cause of great
internal conflict for Nayla but she
trusts in the will of god the god infra
had also implanted technology of XE and
manufacture inside of nailless head
which would allow him to speak directly
to her if he wished
Nayla wonders whether there may be a
computer inside but dismisses the
thought or it was God who put it there
Nayla reported on all of C ona's actions
to the god emperor her faith in him was
unquestionable even if ciona sends you
to kill me you must obey she must never
learn that you served me no one can kill
you Lord but you must obey ciona of
course Lord that is your command you
must obey her in all things I will do it
Lord
nailless faith was such that even Leto
himself could not shake her any obstacle
she viewed as a test this religion built
around my purse and disgust me yes Lord
Neela's green eyes on the gilded
cushions of her cheeks stared out at him
without questioning without
comprehension without the need of either
response if I sent her out to collect
the star she would go and she would
attempt it she thinks I am testing her
again I do believe she could anger me
this damnable religion should end with
me Leto shouted why should I want to
loose a religion upon my people
religions wrecked from within empires
and individuals alike it's all the same
yes Lord
religions create radicals and fanatics
like you thank you Lord the short-lived
pseudo Rage sank back out of sight into
the depths of his memories
nothing denied the hard surface of
nailless faith Nayla is the perfect
example of pure fanaticism see own
Atreides is the descendant of ghanima
Atreides in Hakala dar once known as
ceratin Corino see ona's intelligence
and charisma has helped her to become a
leader of a group of like-minded rebels
they are determined to end the rule of
the god emperor she plans to give copies
of Latos journals to groups whose
loyalty to the god emperors questionable
including the Bene Gesserit sisterhood
the guild and the ex Ian's Siana does
not find the location of Latos spiced
hoard but she does discover something
else
zeona shows Nayla a flower and a strand
of hair which she found pressed in
between two pages of paper on the paper
read a strand of ghanima hair with a
star flower blossom which she once
brought me on another page was written
words I wrote when told of ghani's death
the sand beach as gray as a dead cheek a
green tide flow reflects cloud ripples I
stand on the dark wet edge cold foam
cleanses my toes I smell driftwood smoke
zeona knew that with these words they
had discovered the key to God's undoing
the god Emperor loved his sister yes he
is capable of love oh yes we have him
now
manao Atreides is si Ana's father and
the closest and most loyal servant to
the god emperor manao acted as majordomo
of late to his household the god Emperor
thinks to himself
what a gift manao has given him in his
daughter seonah knowing that she is the
new while he himself is a collection of
the old and obsolete a crypt of
ancestral knowledge a relic ciona was
more important to Leto
than she or Moneo knew seona had the
ability to vanish from Latos prescient
vision at times though she was not aware
she would fade and yet the golden path
would remain but see ona in fact was not
prescient herself she was unique see ona
hath potential if she survived Latos
test that is to be the one who could
offer humanity a clean slate the
ultimate goal of Latos breeding program
someone who could hide from the
prescient view and spread those genes
throughout all mankind manao in his
youth had been a rebel justice see ona
is now in fact most of Latos trusted
administrators had once been rebels
according to Leto rebels made for the
best administrators and all rebels were
closeted aristocrats which was why he
was able to convert them so easily later
seemingly in contradiction to the
statement Leto says that in order to
identify rebels he looks for men with
principles principles he said are what
we fight for most men go through a
lifetime unchallenged except at the
final moment they have so few unfriendly
arenas in which to test themselves they
have you she said but I am so powerful
he said I am the equivalent of suicide
who would seek certain death madmen or
desperate ones
rebels I am their equivalent to war he
said the ultimate predator
I am the cohesive force which shatters
them Leto says that a good administrator
is incorruptible shrewd philosophical
and open about their errors and quick to
see decisions the difference between a
good administrator and a bad
administrator is the fact that a good
administrator can make immediate choices
act on instinct a bad administrator
hesitates eventually acting in ways that
create serious problems Monell is
concerned for his daughter's safety but
makes sure that the God in / knows that
his own concerns are paramount manao
knows that ciona is dangerous and has
placed a spy amongst her which Leto
already knows
Siana provides Leto with surprise due to
her ability to hide from his presence
but she also reminds Leto of what he
fears most of all the sameness and
repetition that could potentially
destroy the golden path see ona is the
contrast by which I know my deepest
fears manao is concern for me is well
grounded I tell you this in the hope
that it will help you understand why I
act as I do in the full knowledge that
great forces accumulate in my Empire
with but one wish to destroy me you who
read these words may know full well what
actually happened but I doubt that you
understand it though the manipulation of
human genetics is forbidden by Latos
religion that laylax who know how much
he treasures his dumpkins they reproduce
golas from the original cells from the
original duncan who died all the way
back in the dune days thus the Duncans
all have the memories up until that
original point of death
the Tleilaxu do this in the hopes that
it will buy them favor with the god
emperor it does not in the opening of
god emperor of dune a new duncan awakes
to a strange new world finding the
planet Arrakis to be unrecognizable and
the shape of the empire to be completely
different to how he remembered it he is
a man out of his time I am Duncan Idaho
that was about all he wanted to know for
sure he did not like the deluxe
two explanations their stories but then
that laylax who had always been feared
disbelieved and feared the new Idaho
sometime after the death of his
predecessor he's escorted down to the
planet Arrakis by clay Locke suface
dancers who make a game out of changing
their faces constantly to confuse him
they then tell him that the women of the
Royal Guard will come for him soon
they leave him there in a dull
featureless room Ida who is confused by
their statement since he is not aware of
Latos all-female army he is aware that
he is a gola he remembered his own death
and could not deny the truth initially
upon awakening he had been a blank slate
there to be programmed in any way that
laylax who wished they unblocked his
memory by repeating the scenario which
awoke hate's memory and Children of Dune
by conditioning him to kill a man so
similar to Paul that Duncan believed
that it was likely a Dola though he
wonders where the dirty Flay laksa would
have gotten the cells of Paul Atreides
the God in virile a Toa sure as a Duncan
that it was no more than a face dancer
mimicked waltz among that laylax ooh
Duncan is allowed to study play lacks in
history he learns of Leto the second who
was born 3,500 years ago and yet still
lives as ruler of the universe but this
second Leto
so the history said had become something
something so strange that Idaho
despaired of understanding the
transformation how could a human slowly
turn into a sand war how could any
thinking creature live more than 3,000
years not even the wildest projections
of the geriatric spice allowed such a
lifespan Duncan doesn't know what to
believe he suspects play Lex who lies it
wouldn't be until he saw the worm
god-emperor
that he would truly believe that lay Lex
who tell Duncan that the god Emperor is
a tyrant and had ordered them to produce
him from their axolotl tanks they do not
know what became of the one before him
the presence of the new Gola pleased the
shadow of Paul Atreides which lived
within Leto Leto had the new Duncan
brought into a dark room where he could
hear Leto speak before he saw his form
what do I call you it was the sign of
acceptance for which Leto had been
waiting well Lord Leto do yes my lord
Idaho stared directly into Latos Freeman
blue eyes is it true what your fish
speakers say you have memories of we are
all here Duncan Leto spoke in the voice
of his paternal grandfather then even
the women are here Duncan it was the
voice of Jessica Latos paternal
grandmother you knew them well Leto said
and they know you when the lights turned
on Duncan saw Latos body and he asked
why Leto had done this to himself
Leto told him that he would know in time
he told the Duncan that eventually his
body would make sandworms of some sort
but they would be aware having more
ganglia more nerve cells though Duncan
begins to accept that Leto is at rabies
he can still sense that something he is
missing something has been stolen from
humankind you've taken something away
from us he said I can feel it
those women manao us against you Leto
thought the Duncan's always choose the
human side Idaho returned his attention
to Leto his face what have you given us
in exchange throughout the Empire Latos
peace Leto tells Duncan that his
so-called peace is actually enforced
tranquility that the fish speakers are
present because humans by nature react
negatively against tranquillity he gives
them this and a hierarchy which they can
easily identify a hierarchy where he is
God though he tells Duncan that in truth
holiness is a curse and that it offends
him but Leto understands that it is
necessary for the golden path which is a
fact that the Duncan cannot yet
comprehend Leto tells the Duncan that
his duty will be
to guard him by any means necessary and
also to guard his secret the secret that
he is in fact vulnerable that he is not
truly God in the ultimate since Duncan
still doesn't fully trust Leto and tells
him that he will turn against him if he
should discover him to be worse than the
harkonnens ultimately Duncan agrees to
serve Leto after the god emperor reminds
him who he truly is when we climb siege
to boar for the last time together you
had my loyalty then and I had yours
nothing of that has really changed that
was your father that was me
Paul Muad'Dib Zeus of command coming
from Leto spoke always shocked the
goalless Idaho whispered all of you in
that one body he broke off later remains
silent this was the decision moment
presently Idaho permitted himself that
devil-may-care grin for which he had
been so well known then I will speak to
first Leto and to Paul the ones who know
me best use me well for I did love you
the Duncan leaves the God in Berlin not
knowing that his words had disturbed him
Leto knew that in fact it was love that
he was most vulnerable to the Bene
Gesserit sisterhood remains unbroken
during the reign of the god emperor Leto
mentions that out of all in the universe
the Binney jazz writ Reverend mothers
are the most like him having access to
their ancestral memories
the bene Jesuit as always make their
plots he is aware of most of their
efforts early on in the novel they
attempt to form an alliance between the
fish speakers and themselves but fail
the fish speakers keep nothing from God
you've been a Jesuit assail me on all
sides even now you seek to suborn my
fish speakers sister chin away says that
she steeled herself for death but the
God Emperor merely stopped his cart and
looked across her at his entourage
she says the other stopped and waited on
the road in well-drained passivity all
of them at a respectful distance the
Lord later said there is my little
multitude and they tell me everything do
not deny my accusation sister Chan oh I
said I do not deny it later commands
chin away to report his words back to
the sisterhood exactly he is fully aware
of her special training as an aural
recorder and of her true mission on
Arrakis he tells her that he will
restore the outward view the spiritual
freedom that humanity had lost humans
had been enclosed trapped behind latches
and locks and most humans were not
strong enough to seek freedom within
themselves he tells the sisterhood that
as they succeeded in creating the
quizlets had iraq he has succeeded in
creating ciona
though he does not elaborate for the
sisterhood the many Jesuit wonder about
the god emperors reference to see ona
and intend to investigate sister chin
away had also been commanded by the god
emperor to withhold certain words from
her report to the sisterhood
when chin away asked Leto about his
likeness to a Reverend Mother he
responded by telling her that he and his
sister were awakened in the womb he told
her that because he knows that she had
been told to record accurately whatever
she heard that he would speak to her as
though he was speaking to one of his
journals he told her to preserve the
words well for he did not want them lost
when she asked him why he had chosen her
he said it was because he would never
see her again she did not understand his
strange words the Lord Leto spoke as
follows to my certain knowledge when I
am no longer consciously present here
among you when I am here only as a
fearsome creature of the desert many
people will look back upon me as a
tyrant fair enough I have been
tyrannical a tyrant not fully human not
insane merely a tyrant but even ordinary
tyrants have motives and feelings beyond
those usually assigned to them by facile
historians and they will think of me as
a great tyrant
thus my feelings and motives are a
legacy I would preserve less history
distort them too much history has a way
of magnifying some characteristics while
it discards others people will try to
understand me and frame me in their
words they will seek truth but the truth
always carries the ambiguity of the
words used to express it you will not
understand me the harder you try the
more remote I will become until finally
I vanish into eternal myth a living God
at last that's it you see I am NOT a
leader nor even a guide a god remember
that I am quite different from leaders
and guides gods need take no
responsibility for anything except
Genesis God's accept everything and thus
accept nothing gods must be identifiable
and yet remain anonymous gods do not
need a spirit world my spirits dwell
within me answerable to my slightest
summons I share with you because it
pleases me to do so what I have learned
about them and through them they are my
truth beware of the truth gentle sister
although much sought after truth can be
dangerous to the seeker myths and
reassuring lies are much easier to find
and believe
if you find a truth even a temporary one
it can demand that you make painful
changes conceal your truth within words
natural ambiguity will protect you then
words are much easier to absorb than the
sharp Delphic stabs of wordless portent
with words you can cry out in the chorus
why didn't someone warn me but I did
warn you
I warned you by example not with words
there are inevitably more than enough
words you record them in your marvelous
memory even now and someday my journals
will be discovered more words I warn you
that you read my words at your peril the
wordless movement of terrible events
lies just below their surface be deaf
you do not need to hear or hearing you
do not need to remember how soothing it
is to forget and how dangerous words
such as mine have long been recognized
for their mysterious power there are
secret knowledge here which can be used
to rule the forgetful my truths are the
substance of myths and lies which
tyrants have always counted on to
maneuver the masses for selfish design
you see I share it all with you even the
greatest mystery of all time the mystery
by which I can pose my life I reveal it
to you in words the only past which
endures lies wordlessly within you he
tells her that he preserves these words
for the future generations of mankind
who will seek to unravel the mysteries
of his rule to find meaning in their own
existence chin away got the sins from
late to his words that he was uttering
some kind of last Testament she asked
the god Emperor if he is telling her
this because he is about to die Leto
laughs no gentle sister it is you who
will die
you will not live to be a reverend
mother do not be saddened by this for by
your presence here today by carrying my
message back to the sisterhood by
preserving my secret words as well you
will achieve a far greater status you
become here an integral part of my myth
our distant cousins will pray to you for
intercession with me Leto has seen
Genoa's death in his prescient vision
and tells herself in that moment the
many Jesuit sister Qin away and the Lord
late tho shares something almost
physical a mutual experience of wordless
truth chin away is unable to describe it
this account was found amongst chin
aways papers after her death she died in
the 53rd year of her sisterhood when she
underwent the spice agony in an attempt
to convert the deadly truth singer
drugged and become a reverend mother the
God Emperor completely denies the
sisterhood any involvement in his
breeding program the fish speaker
Garrison's on the Benny J's rat
homeworld kill the children of the
sisterhood who result from genetic lines
which they object to as a result the
sisterhood struggles to maintain their
level of Reverend mothers when the
sisterhood protested this to the god
Emperor he responded with a warning be
thankful for what you have the
sisterhood understood the sisterhood
does not question Latos prescient
abilities and know him to be more
powerful than any before him they
believe that he knows every important
action that they will take prior to the
event and therefore guide themselves by
the rule that they will never knowingly
threaten his person or his grand plan
which they can discern parts of the
Sisterhood's official addressed to the
god Emperor is as follows tell us if we
threaten you that we may desist and tell
us of your grand plan that we may help
the sisterhood is also aware that the
guild and the ex Ian's worked together
to develop a mechanical substitute to
the prescient power of an avid
The Sisterhood does not suspect that
much will come of this though they are
watchful the success of the project
could mean the reduction of the god
Emperor's power in the universe since
spice would no longer be required for
safe space travel the god emperor has
many devices of exceed manufacture many
of them defy the prescriptions of the
butler Ginn jihad containing Thinking
Machines early on in his reign Leto had
revealed to the ex Ian's that he knew
the secret location of their exceed core
the heartland of their technological
Federation he had seen the location in
his prescience the technology of the XE
ins is feared throughout the empire only
once have the Exxon's attempted to trick
him with a violent device he had killed
the entire delegation before the package
was even opened in the novel the exeunt
send a new ambassador to the court of
the god Emperor we nori shortly after
her arrival on the planet she meets with
the god Emperor and just as the XE ins
have planned Leto is immediately
attracted to her her uncle Maki had once
been boon companion to the Lord Leto
he knew the God Emperor better than
perhaps even manao the god Emperor finds
both her physical beauty and her truly
pure personality to be intoxicating Leto
understands that the ex Egan's have
uncovered his secret his vulnerability
Leto had known that they had been
working on something he couldn't see it
but he knew when something vanished from
his prescient view hui nori had been
raised in a no chamber a device that the
ex Ian's had developed from the same
technology than he used to record his
journals anno chamber hid whatever was
inside from prescence
who Inori had been bred specifically to
appeal to the final remnants of humanity
within Leto he has become more and more
alien with the passage of time he longed
to feel again the ex Ian's hoped that
they could use weinery
to tempt Leto away from his golden path
hooey was merely upon and meant late
till no harm consciously late to could
not bring himself to dismiss Hui nori
and he could not kill her the Xen plot
had worked Leto decides instead that she
will be his bride
the god emperor is incapable of physical
intimacy thus and vectors of his body
reacted to even the slightest hints of
moisture he tells weinery
that she would be allowed to take a
lover if she so chose she accepts the
god Emperor's proposal we are myth
killers you a diamond ayo that is the
dream we share I show you from a God's
Olympian perch that government is a
shared myth when the myth dies the
government dies Latos golden path if
successful will lead to a new way of
existing for humankind Leto knew that
governments were only useful to the
governed as long as the governments
inherent tendencies Tour's tyranny were
restrained
I can imagine your inward travels Lord
no you cannot I have seen peoples and
planets in such numbers that they lose
meaning even in imagination
oh the landscapes I have passed the
calligraphy of alien roads glimpsed from
space and imprinted upon my innermost
sight the eroded sculpture of canyons
and cliffs and galaxies has imprinted
upon me the certain knowledge that I am
Moute not you Lord certainly not you
less than moat
I have seen people and their fruitless
societies and such repetitive posturings
that their nonsense fills me with
boredom do you hear I did not mean to
anger you my lord manao speaks meekly
you do not anger me sometimes you
irritate me that is the extent of it you
cannot imagine what I have seen caliphs
and Majid's rokkes and Rajas and
Bashar's kings and emperors primitives
and presidents I have seen them all
feudal chieftains everyone everyone a
little Pharaoh the GaN Emperor
understood that governments always
trended towards increasingly despotic
states humans naturally sought out
tribal hierarchies filling an ancient
demand forces
system in which every individual knows
his place Leto believed that knowing
one's place was valuable even if that
place was temporary but to be held in
place against her will was another thing
entirely Leto had imposed this stillness
upon the entire universe such was his
tyranny but this was his lesson to all
mankind
beware of the liberties you offer up to
your leaders even though you read these
words after a passage of Young's my
tyranny shall not be forgotten my Golden
Path assures this knowing my message I
expect you to be exceedingly careful
about the powers you delegate to any
government manao had been the god
emperors major domo for the past 79
years he was truly the god Emperor's
creature manao somewhat resented Duncan
hi-de-ho golas because of the special
connection they shared with Leto their
mutual memories from the Dune days and
before as I said before manao had once
been a rebel just as his daughter see
ona is now as a gift to manao
Leto takes ciona out of harm's way by
forcing her to join his fish speakers
and soon he will test her as he once
tested manao manao in his youth had been
placed in a massive maze concealed
beneath Leto citadel he was given only a
bag of food and a vial of the deadly
spice essence the truth seer drug which
caught on blocked genetic memory it was
the only liquid Leto gave him manao was
a tradies he knew he would be exposed to
the intr multitude upon consumption of
the drug and he feared this more than
dying of thirst
he knew however that he had no choice
after wandering the maze for hours he
finally consumes the drug he heard the
ancestral voices and his prescient eye
was open he saw what the god Emperor saw
he saw what Paul Atreides had seen and
ran from those many thousands of years
ago he saw Humanity's extinction and
also the means by which it could be
diverted the golden path
manao now understood after this he awoke
knowing the way out of the maze and
knowing that he would serve the god
emperor to the end of his days and he
served him faithfully since that day
manao had been enlightened by the golden
path he was terrified of the idea of the
world without Leto he would rather die
than face such an existence the new
Duncan however has begun to see Latos
rule as corruption as he has gotten to
know the world around him he began to
believe that Latos rule of the Empire
was one of religious tyranny and
oppression Idaho naturally rebelled
against this Idaho is even more
disturbed upon witnessing the children
of his predecessor as well as the widow
who Duncan notices has a striking
resemblance to the lady Jessica the god
emperor has intended to breed ciona and
duncan and has forced them into
situations where they must be together
both seola and Duncan resent the god
Emperor for trying to control them in
this manner seola is the key to
hastening Duncan's disillusionment with
the god Emperor giving him insight on
the true goings-on in the worms Empire
Duncan had been immediately attracted to
the Xen ambassador we nori upon seeing
her but the god infra had commanded him
to avoid her saying we is not for you
when the GaN Emperor decided to Wed who
Inori manao voiced his own apprehensions
pointing out that this was obviously
part of some exeunt plot but Leto is in
fact vulnerable he loves we only around
her does his loneliness fade
Duncan is revolt by the thought of Leto
wetting we he speaks of frontiers and
questions the Lord later on whether he
would truly be free to do what he wished
and go where he wished Leto tells him
that he is free to go as he chooses I
have given you my oath that is important
to me it is still important I don't know
what you're doing or why I can only say
I don't like what's happening there I've
said it
Leto sees Duncan as a child and thanks
to himself that Duncan is both the
oldest and youngest man in the universe
Duncan disobeys the God
however which angers him when the god
emperor speaks to Monell after his
arrival back from the festival city
manao could since the coming of the worm
manao believed truly that there were two
lay two and the worm
it was the worm that killed the worm who
was God Leto inhabited God Leto demands
that manao accelerate the plans for the
wedding manao attempts to come the god
in for her by stating that nori merely
feel sorry for Duncan
but Leto knows that he is courting her
he is clever with women manao
exceedingly clever he sees into their
souls and makes them do what he wants it
has always been that way with the
Duncans I did not know you had
prohibited all meetings between them
Lord manase voice was almost strident he
is more dangerous than any of the others
Leto said it is the fault of our times
Lord the Telex who do not have a
successor for him ready to deliver and
we need this one you said it yourself
Lord it is a paradox which I do not
understand what you did say it
how long until there could be a
replacement at least a year Lord shall I
inquire as to a specific date do it
today he may hear about it Lord the
previous one did I do not want it to
happen this way mone oh I know Lord and
I dare not speak of this to nori later
said the Donkin is not for her yet I
cannot hurt her the last was almost a
wail manao stood in awed silence can't
you see this later demanded money Oh
helped me kou Inori
and Duncan have fallen for each other
which upsets the God Emperor he does not
wish to hurt her
this makes him vulnerable monel then
starts to see the signs of the coming of
the worm the god emperor's hands begin
to twitch at his eyes glazed over manao
takes a step back feeling exposed
knowing that a mere flick of the great
body would kill him I must appeal to the
human in him manao brings up Latos
sister Janina they
been wet but not mates he asked Leto if
it would be possible for him to mate
with weed nori but the warm signs only
intensified Latos hands vibrated
spasmodically in a very distant voice he
tells manao not to question him about
possibilities manao can hear that Leto
is sinking further and further into that
inner gate which only he could enter
manao slowly backed out of the room
trembling ah that was the closest ever
and the paradox remained where did it
point what was the meaning of the god
emperor Zod and painful decisions what
brought the worm who is God a thumping
sounded from within Leto sorry
a heavy beating against stone manao
dared not opened the door to investigate
he pushed himself away from the surface
which reflected that dreadful thumping
and went down the stairs moving
cautiously not drawing an easy breath
until he reached the ground level and
the fish speak regard there is he
disturbed she asked looking up the
stairs manao nodded they both could hear
the thumping quite plainly what disturbs
him the guard asked he is God and we are
mortal manao said duncan has put them
all in danger and manao cannot help but
resent him even more he wonders what can
be done about who Inori manao goes to
Duncan and tells him of the god
Emperor's wishes his relationship with
who Inori can not continue it only
angers Duncan more manao sees now that
this duncan is more reckless than any of
the others before him and insist that he
must trust the god emperor but the
duncan says aloud how can a God do evil
things the fish speaker women in the
room without a doubt heard this and
would make their reports to the Lord
Leto had it been any other man other
than Duncan Idaho who spoke those words
the women themselves would have
eliminated him
Duncan becomes paranoid and wonders what
the god-emperor will do but in his
chambers he finds wee nori there she had
been told to reject Duncan as Duncan
looks at her he is reminded of the
controlled movements of the lady Jessica
and realizes that we nori his many
Jesuit trained the bene Jesuit were
indeed among her teachers though she is
not a member of the sisterhood
who we cannot deny her attraction to
Duncan though the God Emperor forbids it
she admits to Duncan that she was bred
and trained for one purpose alone to woo
the God Emperor she was designed to
please and Atreides and Duncan had
always truly been a tradies Hui and
Duncan make love then but afterwards she
tells him that they never will again be
together in this way she tells him that
she will tell the god Emperor of what
they have done she knows that Leto will
not harm her and he will not harm the
Duncan for this would destroy her in
turn who he truly understands that Leto
needs her more than Duncan though Duncan
argues he only resents Leto even more
finally Leto and ciona meet he summons
her to him she asks him if he is really
a God she does not understand why her
father manao believes in him but he does
not necessarily answer her she asked why
he has done what he has done why he has
chosen to become this monstrosity but he
does not directly answer gradually as
they spoke Leto had been dimming the
concealed lights of his Airy moving his
cart closer and closer to seonah now he
shut off the lights leaving only the
moon the front of his cart protruded
onto the balcony his face about two
metres from seonah my father tells me
she said that the older you get the
slower your time goes is that what you
told him testing my veracity he thought
she is not a truth singer then all
things are relative but compared to the
human time since this is true why it is
involved in what I will become
at the end time will stop for me and I
will be frozen like a pearl caught in
ice my new bodies will scatter each with
a pearl hidden within it she turned and
looked away from him peering out at the
desert speaking without looking at him
when I talked to you like this here in
the darkness I can almost forget what
you are
when ciona asked Leto to turn on the
lights she wonders why his face is not
wrinkled he tells her that nothing about
his human parts age in a normal way she
wonders if he did this for long life but
he assures her that he did not he tells
her the truth about his metamorphosis
that since she is a tradies she could to
be like him if there are other sand
trout around the thought of it makes her
shiver but she knows that it is the
truth once again she asked why but he
said that she will know in time Leto
tells seonah of his secret the secret
that she already knows he tells her of
the companions that he has loved that
have slipped away from him of her mother
who slipped away long ago and her father
who is slipping away now he is wracked
with emotion each time for many
centuries this suffering was the only
emotion he knew ciona sympathizes with
the god emperor but insist that this
does not give him the right to govern
and Leto knew this was the root of her
rebellion by what right where is the
justice in my rule by imposing my rules
upon them with the weight of fish
speaker arms am i being fair to the
evolutionary thrust of mankind as
intended Latos conversation with ciona
leaves her wide open to her own doubts
she still insists that she had not been
convinced of anything by their meeting
she asked what the purpose of it was he
tells her that the purpose is to see if
she was ready to be tested which
obviously frightens her don't play
innocent with me
manao has told you and i tell you that
you are ready she tried to swallow then
water I have sit form a nail to return
you to the citadel he said
we meet again we will really learn what
you are made of when the god-emperor
next speaks to manao he asked how soon
the clerks who can provide a replacement
Duncan manao tells him that the play
lacks who report problems manao believes
that the worm may soon approach the god
emperor grows increasingly agitated with
the behavior of the current Duncan his
subversion was occurring far more
quickly than anticipated manao was aware
of the many deaths that had occurred in
the crypts in which they resided he
wonders judging by the way the god
Emperor is speaking if it is his time to
die failure to respond to the God
Emperor correctly he believed would mean
his death abruptly Latos voice filled
the chamber with a rumbling baritone an
ancient voice which spoke across the
centuries you are servants unto gods not
servants on 2/7 when they are rung his
hands out and cried I serve you Lord man
AO manao his voice low and resonant a
million wrongs cannot give rise to one
right the right is known because it
endures manao could only stand in
trembling silence I had intended weed to
mate with you
manao Leto said now it is too late the
words took a moment penetrating Monet's
consciousness he felt that their meaning
was out of any known context we who was
we oh yes the god inverse exam
bride-to-be mate with me manao shook his
head
Leto spoke with infinite sadness you too
shall pass away will all of your works
be as dust forgotten without any warning
even as he spoke Latos body convulsed in
a thrashing roll which heaved him from
the cart the speed of it the monstrous
violence threw him within centimeters of
manao who screamed and fled across the
crypt manao Latos call stopped the
majordomo at the entrance to the lift
the testimony oh I will test
zeona tomorrow zeona asks her father
about the test
she asked him what will happen to her he
tells her that each test is different
Leto had listened to them secretly
through his exceed devices as manao
dressed his
in a traditional frame and still suit he
told her that the worm would come and
that she must find a way to live in his
presence he explained still suit to her
and how it worked and told her that she
must go but that she may not return Leto
brings ciona into his desert the only
desert remaining on the planet Arrakis
the isolated desert climate was
maintained by Xen devices Leto can move
swiftly in his own territory
it was his domain they look out onto the
desert together this was how it was he
said he knew that there was something in
the desert that spoke to the eternal
soul of those who possessed Freeman
blood he tells ciona to climb upon his
back I want you to taste the way our
people what's moved proudly across this
land high atop the back of a giant
sandwich Leto knows that ciona still has
no idea how he intends to test her he
knew that he must have no pity he leads
them both deeper into the desert he
sensed it when ciona begin to enjoy the
sensation of riding on his back he felt
a faint shift in her weight as she eased
back onto her legs to lift her head
he drove outward then along the curving
beragon joining ciona and enjoyment of
the old sensations once he tells her to
come down she is distrustful she is
afraid that he will leave her there he
tells her that they have traveled 60
kilometers he tells her that now that
she has felt her past she must be
sensitized to her future
he has brought her to the center of the
desert he tells her that they will walk
out of the desert together she only has
a small pouch of food to sustain her he
tells her that they will travel by night
in the traditional freman way meanwhile
Idaho has sought out manao and angrily
demands to know where Leto is I'll find
him manao
not right now Idaho put a hand on his
knife do I have to use force to make you
talk I would not advise that where is he
since you insist he is out in the desert
with ciona with your daughter
is there another ciona what are they
doing she is being tested
when will they return manao shrugged
then why this unseemly anger Duncan
what's this test of your I don't know
now why are you so upset I'm sick of
this place
fish speakers Duncan had glimpse to fish
speaker women joined together in a kiss
this disturbed his archaic sensibilities
manao said it is perfectly normal for
adolescent females as well as males to
have feelings of physical attraction
toward members of their own sex most of
them will grow out of it it should be
stamped out but it's part of our
heritage Idaho insist that this rampant
homosexuality must be suppressed but
wiser manao understood that an attempt
to suppress such a thing only increases
its power
Idaho shifts the conversation to the
topic of ciona and attempts to shame a
nail for allowing the worm to test her
knowing that she may never return manao
wonders to himself why he puts up with
such a foolish person as duncan idaho
and he responds that he had no choice he
insists to duncan idaho that he must
mature I am NOT some damn child you can
Duncan it was the loudest sound Idaho
had ever heard from the mild mannered
manao surprise stayed Idaho's hand while
manao continued if the demands of your
flesh are for maturity but something
holds you in adolescence quite nasty
behavior develops let go are you
accusing me of
no manao gestured at the corridor oh I
know what you must have seen back there
but it two women in a passionate kiss
you think that's not it's not important
youth explores potential in many ways
Idaho balanced himself on the edge of an
explosion rocking forward on his toes
I'm glad to learn about you man
yes well I've learned about you several
times manao watched the effect of these
words as they twisted through Idaho
tangling him the goalless could never
avoid a fascination with the others who
had preceded them
Idaho spoke in a hoarse whisper what
have you learned you have taught me
valuable things manao said all of us try
to evolve but if something blocks us we
can transfer our potential into pain
seeking it or giving it adolescents are
particularly vulnerable Idaho leaned
close to me oh I'm talking about sex of
course you are are you accusing me of
adolescent that's right I should cut
your oh shut up my nails response did
not have the training nuances of been a
Jesuit voice-control but it had a
lifetime of command behind it something
in Idaho could only obey I'm sorry
manao said but I am distracted by the
fact that my only daughter he broke off
and shrugged Idaho inhaled two deep
breaths you're crazy all of you you say
your daughter may be dying and yet you
fool manao snapped have you any idea how
your petty concerns appear to me your
stupid questions and your selfish he
broke off shaking his head I make
allowances because you have certain
problems Idaho said but if you
allowances you make allowances my nail
took a trembling breath it was too much
I had a host spoke stiffly I can forgive
you for you you prattle about sex and
forgiving and pained and you think you
and we nori leave her out of this oh yes
leave her out leave out that pain you
share sex with her and you never think
about parting
tell me fool how do you give of yourself
in the face of that abashed idaho inhale
deeply he had not suspected such passion
smoldering in the quiet manao but this
attack this could not be you think I'm
cruel manao demanded I make you think of
things you'd rather avoid huh crueler
things have been done to the Lord Leto
for no better reason than the cruel
you defend him you I know him best he
uses you to what ins you tell me he is
our best hope to perpetuate perverts do
not perpetuate manao spoke in a soothing
tone but his word shook Idaho I will
tell you this only once homosexuals have
been among the best warriors in our
history the berserkers of last resort
they were among our best priests and
priestesses celibacy was no accident in
religions manao attempts to guide Duncan
out of his backward viewpoint but Duncan
resists at every turn constantly
questing for something else to hate
about Latos Empire you suggested that he
uses me manao sin I permit this because
I know the price that he pays is much
greater than what he demands of me even
your daughter he holds back nothing why
should I
oh I think you understand this about the
Atreides the Duncan's are always good at
that
the Duncan's damn you I won't be you
just haven't the guts to pay the price
he's asking manao said in one blurred
motion idaho whipped his knife from its
sheath and lunged at manao as fast as he
moved manao moved faster sidestepping
tripping idaho and propelling him face
down on the floor idaho scrambled
forward rolled and started to leap to
his feet then hesitated realizing that
he had actually tried to attack and
Atreides manao was at Randy's shock held
idaho immobile manao stood unmoving
looking down at him there was an odd
look of sadness on the majordomo face if
you are going to kill me don't
you'd best do it in the back by stealth'
manao said you might succeed that way
idaho levered himself to one knee put a
foot flat on the floor but remained
there still clutching his knife manao
had moved so quickly and with such grace
so so casually idaho cleared his throat
how did you
he has been breeding us for a long time
Duncan strengthening many things in us
he has bred us for speed for
intelligence for self-restraint for
sensitivity you're you're just an older
model the tension that had been building
between Duncan and manao finally comes
to a peak in this scene when Duncan
Idaho attacks manao but then is met with
the shock of Mao's incredible agility
and speed
Duncan Idaho is nothing compared to
thousands of years of precise genetic
honing after this Idaho self-esteem
drops he begins to see himself as
obsolete and wonders if he should kill
himself
he only resents Leto even more Monet's
words echoed in his mind
you're just an older model as Leto and
seonah moved through the desert they
spoke sporadically he told her of
Freeman history and in the afternoon she
crept close to him for the warmth his
body generated in excess Leto noticed at
sea ona was not utilizing the face slap
in her still suit this would cause the
body to lose moisture much faster but he
could not intervene it was part of the
test as their time in the desert
continues ciona grows weaker she leaned
against him once and heard the rumbling
of his insights later saw that she was
cold he allowed her to curl up inside a
depression at the bottom of his first
segment in order to keep warm
Leto knew that he had to resist feeling
pity for seona since knowing weinery
his human emotions had become more
amplified than they had been in
centuries zeona inched closer to death
as time went on Leto prepared himself
for her failure and considered her
replacement
once Leto had made callous decisions
with ease
but as he grew increasingly inhuman he
found himself to be consumed with
increasingly more human concerns it was
only on the third day that ciona
remembered Monet's explanation of the
still suit by this point however ciona
had lost a considerable amount of water
five days in late oak and since Tiana's
desperation and knows that she will soon
reach a moment of crisis he tells her
that there are three nights until they
find water she knows that she will not
make it once again she asked why he does
what he does he tells her truthfully
that he has a need to save the threads
of all humankind he says that without
him by this point in history all of
humankind would already be extinct and
the path to that extinction would have
been more hideous than she could have
ever possibly imagined he assures her
that the two of them are in fact
interdependent and when she asked what
need he has of her he responds by saying
this you are the Golden Path he said me
it was barely a whisper you've read
those journals you stole from me he said
I am in them but where are you look at
what I have created ciona and you you
can create nothing except yourself words
more tricky words I do not suffer from
being worshipped Ziona
I suffer from never being appreciated
perhaps no I dare not hope for you
what's the purpose of those journals and
Ixia new xin records them they are to be
found on a faraway day they will make
people think and exceed machine you defy
the jihad there is a lesson in that -
what do such machines really do they
increase the number of things we can do
without thinking things we do without
thinking there's the real danger
look at how long you walked across this
desert without thinking about your
facemask
you could have warned me and increased
your dependency ciona still does not yet
understand what Leto means in insisting
that she is the golden path but she is
shocked by his admission to defying the
but Larian jihad he tells her that it is
not the machines that are the danger but
the thoughtless things that humans can
do using those machines in truth Leto
fears the excellence knowing that they
can invent catastrophe Leto knew that
all of history was a race between
invention and catastrophe zeona asked
what she must do for him in order to
save her he tells her that she must
undergo the spiced agony and she knows
what the spice will do to her
considering her a trade these blood
these curled flaps beside my face he
said tease one of them gently with a
finger and it will give up drops of
moisture heavily laced with the Spice
essence ciona leaned towards him and
licked the drops off his flap and
resealed the still soot mask over her
eyes she refitted herself into Latos
front segment she jerked abruptly and
begin to tremble like a small creature
dying he knew this experience but could
not change the smallest part of it
no ancestral presences would remain in
her consciousness but she would carry
with her forever afterward the clear
sights and sounds of smells the seeking
machines would be there the smell of
blood and entrails
the cowering humans in their burrows
aware that they could not escape while
all the time the mechanical movement
approached nearer and nearer and nearer
louder and louder Leto could feel see
ona's life ebbing he could feel the
vitality draining out of her slipping
away she was falling into darkness Leto
rocked her gently like a baby in a
cradle eventually the trembling subsided
ciona awoke late afternoon
and did not speak for an hour turning
her back on Leto she had seen everything
you could have saved my friends in the
forest she accused you too could have
saved them she clenched her fist and
pressed them against her temples while
she glared at him but you know
everything
zeona did I have to learn it that way
she whispered he remained silent forcing
her to answer the question for herself
she had to be made to recognize that his
primary consciousness worked in a
Freeman way and that like the terrible
machines of that apocalyptic vision the
predator could follow any creature who
left tracks the Golden Path she
whispered I could feel it
then glaring at him it's so cruel
survival has always been cruel they
couldn't hide she whispered then loud
what have you done to me you tried to be
a free man rebel he said Freeman had an
almost incredible ability to read signs
on the desert they could even read the
faint tracery of windblown tracks in
sand Leto muses about what they have
seen in the vision the machines that
would hunt and kill any living creature
who left tracks ciona and her dissidents
would leave no tracks seonah saw the
golden path saw what it prevented she
saw the thing that humans could not hide
from the thing that would hunt and kill
every living thing in the universe
zeona still hates Leto however and she
has realized that he cannot find her in
his prescient view he tells her that she
hates the Predators necessary cruelty he
tells her that she must breed and
preserve her precious genes as Latos
spoke a sudden bout of rain covered them
for an instant a malfunction of his
exceed weather machines
zeona did not immediately notice the
effect it had on Leto he curled into a
ball of agony felt as though he was
being ripped apart blue smoke drifted
from his body as he involuntarily began
to produce true spy
essence not the altered form that he had
used to test ciona
which did not allow her to retain
genetic memory ciona realizes that the
water hurts him he tells her about the
relationship of sand route to water in
that moment Leto could see that there
was still rebellion in her eyes she
could not deny the reality of his golden
path but in her mind his cruel T's could
not be forgiven
he knows what ciona is thinking but will
do nothing against her she must live
after their return from the desert Leto
makes the ona a Guard commander still
she plots his destruction and now Duncan
Idaho plots along with her and now that
ciona knows the secret of the god
Emperor's demise ring him with water she
is certain that she can kill him
zeona says that she will not break her
oath that she will command his fish
speakers but it will not be as he wishes
or so she thought zeona was a tradies
and she opposed the god emperor so
duncan was just to fight Leto was no
true human after all
zeona was a real Atreides together they
plot the murder of the god emperor
Nayla who has sworn to obey ciona in all
things has no choice but to help knowing
that her god will perform a miracle the
god emperor grows increasingly agitated
as his wedding draws nearer only Huy
nori seems to calm him
I have no inner eye no inner voices she
said but I have seen my lord Leto whose
soul I love and I know the only thing
that you truly understand he broke from
her gaze fearful of what she might say
the trembling of his hands could be felt
all through his front segments love that
is what you understand she said love and
that is all of it his hands stopped
trembling a tear rolled down each of his
cheeks when the tears touched his cowl
wisp a blue smoke erupted he sensed the
burning and was thankful for the pain
the Exxon's had intended for Leto to
love we but not for her to love him that
was beyond their planning Leto sheds a
tear in the scene a thing which he had
previously believed was impossible Leto
was more inhuman that he had ever been
before we offered him an opportunity to
restore his humanity for one final
fleeting moment as the Royal cart
carrying the god Emperor and weinery
crosses the bridge leading into - ah no
village manao heard the lace gun it was
Nayla who had fired from the cliffs at
the command of ciona manao felt the
bridge shake underneath him he saw the
god Emperor's cart leaned over the edge
of the bridge we nori fell silently to
her death her last words echoed in
lintels mind I shall go on ahead love a
deep rumbling groan had come from Leto
then and in that moment another Lai's
gun blast hit directly striking the
Royal cart suspense errs as manao fell
he reaches a final point of awareness
the clarity of mine that one experiences
before death as he plunges to his death
he turns to see Leto fall from the Royal
cart he shouted Leto see Anouk
I believe he fell freely then in the
ecstasy of awareness
as Leto fell toward the river beneath he
thought to himself now you will learn it
is time for humanity to know his final
lesson Leto fell into pure agony he
marveled that he could remain conscious
through such incredible pain he could
feel himself separating as the sand
trout of his body detached from him and
went into the water they would
eventually emerge as a new breed of
worms spice in the future will be more
difficult to harvest for each worm would
have a piece of the god-emperor inside a
fragmentation of his whole self puffs of
blue smoke and mist rise all around him
as his body produces the spiced essence
somehow he pulls himself from the water
he recognizes the place then just down
the barrier wall was the remains to
seach to Bohr where he had hidden his
immense hoard of spice he turned in the
confinement of the cave and saw a rope
dangling at the entrance a figure slid
down the Rope he recognised Nayla she
dropped to the rocks and crouched there
staring into the shadows at him the
flame which was Latos vision parted to
reveal another figure dropping from the
rope see ona she and nailless scrambled
toward him and a rattle of rocks and
stopped peering at him a third figure
dropped off the rope idaho he moved with
a frantic rage hurling himself at Nayla
screaming why did you kill her you
weren't supposed to kill Hui Nayla sent
him sprawling with a casual almost
indifferent sweep of her left arm she
scrambled up closer to the rocks and
stopped on all fours to peer at Leto
Lord you live idaho was right behind her
snatching the leis gun from her holster
Nayla turned astonished as he leveled
the weapon and pulled the trigger
the burning started at the top of
nailless head it split her the pieces
slumping apart ciona and duncan gaze
upon Leto the sand trout skin had fled
into the water he was parked with cilia
holes from where they had left he was a
disgusting sludge
look at what you've done to poor Duncan
Latos said he'll find other loves how
callous she sounded an echo of his own
angry youth you do not know what love is
he said what have you ever given
he could only wring his hands then those
travesties which once had been his hands
gods below what I've given she sled
closer and reached toward him then drew
back
I am reality see onna look upon me I
exist you gotta touch me if you dare
reach out to your hand do it slowly
she reached toward what had been his
front segment the place where she had
slept in the sarire her hand was touched
with blue when she withdrew it you have
touched me and felt my body he said is
that not strange beyond any other thing
in this universe she started to turn
away no don't turn away from me look at
what you have rocked see ona how is it
that you can touch me but you cannot
touch yourself she whirled away from him
there is the difference between us he
said you are God embodied you walk
around with the greatest miracle of this
universe yet you refuse to touch or see
or feel or believe in it as Leto died he
could sense his Xen devices working
recording his thoughts on radula and
crystals Leto thanks to his journals
remember what I did remember me I will
be innocent again the journals will be
his record of the truth
the version undistorted by history he
says to duncan let them scatter let them
run and hide anywhere they want and in a
universe they choose referencing the
great scattering of mankind that will
occur following his death he tells
duncan that the fish speakers will
choose to follow him over Ceylon he
asked Duncan to be kind to her he tells
him that ciona is more than a tradies
and that she carries the seed of the
survival of all human
late hotels seona and Duncan where his
spice board is hidden Duncan knows the
place one final time Duncan asked why
why has Leto done any of this
Leto answers my gift later said nobody
will find the descendants of Ziona
the Oracle cannot see her what they
spoke in unison leaning close to hear
his fading voice I give you a new kind
of time without parallels he said it
will always diverge
there will be no concurrent points on
its curves I give you the golden path
that is my gift never again will you
have the kinds of concurrence at once
you had Leto dies as his consciousness
is fragmented and the gross Hulk that
was his body disintegrates into puddles
of blue mist ciona tells Duncan that
though she is different she is still
what later was she walked amongst her
inner lives what was unseen and could
only glimpse blurred shapes of her
ancestral past enough to light the
golden path you know the myth of the
great spice horde yes I know about that
story too a majordomo brought it to me
one day to amuse me the story says there
is a horde of mélange a gigantic horde
big as a great mountain the horde is
concealed in the depths of a distant
planet it is not Baracus that planet it
is not doomed
the spice was hidden there long ago even
before the first Empire and the spacing
guild the story says that Paul Muad'Dib
went there and lives yet beside the
Horde kept alive by it waiting the
majordomo did not understand why the
story disturbed me the story of the
great spice horde may have disturbed the
god emperor for several reasons in some
sense Paul did live on kept alive by a
giant spice horde MOA deed still lived
within the hordes of Latos mind
eternally observing the story may also
disturb Leto because it represents the
very thing he was trying to destroy the
story indicated that humankind still
longed for their Messiah their Savior
who would solve their problems and
restore the Empire to the way it once
was this mentality was incompatible with
the golden path but what is the golden
path exactly
it starts with one basic idea if one
individual could rule over all mankind
then one threat could destroy it this is
the essential lesson that he had to
teach mankind centralized leaders must
be avoided at all cost he became the
greatest despot of all time so that
humans would always remember and never
return to their past behaviors there is
more Leto saw the death of all humankind
if he did not intervene in the stolen
journals Leto muses to himself and who
knows what the Xen smite manufacture or
invent who knows I certainly don't not
all of it
Leto understood that once the magic of
technology was unleashed that it could
never be put back in the box the ex
Ian's had tried to hide a colony beyond
his vision it had failed he tolerated
the ex Ian's though he called them
criminals of science the exams operated
in the terra incognita of creative
invention which had been outlawed by the
butler in jihad they made their devices
in the image of the mind the very thing
which had ignited the Jihad's
destruction and
that was what they did on X and Leto
could only let them continue but Leto
knew that he would not have to worry as
long as he succeeded in his breeding
program once he knew that ciona was the
one he no longer feared what the XE ins
would create his final words to Duncan
and ciona
are do not fear the X ends they can make
the machines but they can no longer make
our Rafael I know I was there ah Rafael
is the cloud darkness of holy judgment
this is a biblical reference Psalm 97 to
clouds and darkness are round about him
righteousness and justice are the
habitation of his throne essentially
Leto was saying that though the ex Ian's
will continue to invent they will never
create God never create a machine that
will be the final judge of all humankind
zeona solved this problem whatever
threat that Leto foresaw would have used
fresh ian's to seek out and destroy all
of mankind
Sione's genes which spread throughout
all the universe during the scattering
would prevent this by forcing mankind to
stagnate confined to their individual
planets for thousands of years
Leto created a restlessness within them
when they were free from his tyranny
they scattered throughout the universe
the Ixion threat would never be able to
find all humans no one individual could
ever again glimpse the whole of humanity
no machine can do as we do the
descendants of Duncan Idaho and ciona
have done how many universes have we
populated none can guess no one person
will ever know does the church fear the
occasional prophet we know that
visionaries cannot see us nor predict
our decisions no death can find all of
humankind
must we of the minority join our fellows
of the scattering before we can be heard
must we leave the original core of
humankind ignorant and uninformed if the
majority drives us out you know we never
again can be found we do not want to
leave we are held here by those pearls
in the sand we are fascinated by the
church's use of the pearl as the Sun of
understanding surely no reasoning human
can escape the journals revelations in
this regard the admittedly fugitive but
vital uses of archaeology must have
their day just as the primitive machine
which Leto concealed his journals can
only teach us about the evolution of our
machines just so that ancient awareness
must be allowed to speak to us it would
be a crime against both historical
accuracy and science for us to abandon
our attempts at communication with those
pearls of awareness which the journals
have located it is later the second lost
in his endless dream or could he be
reawakened to our times brought to full
consciousness as a storehouse of
historical accuracy
how can Holy Church fear this truth for
the minority we have no doubt that
historians must listen to that voice
from our many beginnings if it is only
the journals we must listen we must
listen across at least as many years
into our future as those journals lay
hidden in our past we will not try to
predict the discoveries yet to be made
within those pages we say only that they
must be made how can we turn our backs
on our most important inheritance as the
poet LAN Brahm --less said
we are the fountain of surprises I hope
you all have enjoyed episode 5 of my
ultimate guide to dune series in the
next episode we will cover heretics of
dune the fifth book in Frank Herbert's
classic dune saga if you would like to
support this channel consider pledging a
dollar or two on patreon
[Music]
[Music]